نريد ان نفهم السياق الذي يقدم فيه سحب
هذه الكتيبه من لواء جولاني وسحب ايضا
جنود اخرين من الويه اخرى من المظليين على
سبيل المثال كيف يقدم ذلك
اسرائيليا نعم تحيه ستاذ زينين مساء الخير
لك وضيوفك الكرام طبعا بطبيعه الحال هذا
الامر وان كانت تحاول اسرائيل ان تعطيه
انطباعا بانه نوع من زياده المعنويات وما
الى ذلك وبالمناسبه اتفق مع اللواء بخصوص
امر واحد يعني الترجمه كانت صحيحه 100% هو
لم يعطي اي سياق حقيقي وهذا ربما يعود ليس
فقط الى ما قاله ذلك الجندي انما الى ما
كيف كيف يتناول الاعلام بطبيعه الحال مع
مجريات الامور في داخل غزه هنالك سياق
واحد تتناوله اسرائيل في كل هذا الخصوص
وهو بث شعور بالامال والنصر هذا الامر
الوحيد الذي تتناوله اسرائيل لا تريد باي
شكل من الاشكال ان تبين ان كل مجريات هذه
الامور تبت من هزيمه معينه وما الى ذلك
يعني ربما فقط صحيفه هارتس الان يعني وان
اطالع بعض الامور عن جولاني تحديدا عشرات
العشرات من القتلى تلقاه جولاني في في
غضون هذه الاسابيع الاخيره
فقط وكذلك بطبيعه الحال ربما مئات الجرحى
بطبيعه الحال جولاني كان ينظر له كنو من
النخبه وهذا يعيدني ربما الى الاسبوع
الاول عندما كانت تتناول اسرائيل موضوع
التوغل البري من عدمه خرج يتسحاك بريك وهو
احد اهم يعني الضباط والجنرالات في
داخل سلاح جيش الاحتلال وقالها بصريح
العباره ربما نحن نملك وهنا ركز على
هذه القضيه تحديدا ربما نملك قوات من
النخبه ذات امتيازات وذات كفاءات عاليه
ووحدات خاصه ذات كفاءات عاليه في اشاره
الى جولاني وغيرها ووحده المظليين وغيرهم
ولكن من يقود الحروب هم جنود المشاه
ولدينا جنود المشاه ما دون المستوى هذا ما
كان قد اشار اليه انذاك يتسحاك بريك يعني
يثير مثير بالنسبه لي للاهتمام الان ان
اسمع تعقيب يسحق بريك على كل مجريات
الامور منذ ذلك التعقيب الى الان هذا
الامر الاول الامر الثاني الذي كذلك يجب
ان نشير اليه وباهتمام باعتقادي هو ان
40% من القتلى في صفوف الجيش هم من ذوي
معتمري القلنسوات اسرائيل بطبيعه الحال
الان موجوده في لحظه توازن معينه بين
معسكرين معسكر المتدينين ومعسكر
العلمانيين ولكن ان يكون
40% من القتلى هم من ذوي القلنسوات وفي
داخل هذا التوجه تحديدا ونحن نتحدث طبعا
عندما تحدثنا 50% من المتدينيين هم
محسوبون عليهم كذلك الحريديم الارثوذكس
الذين لا يتجندون بالمجمل لكن عندما يكون
هذا الرقم هو رقم قياسي و وكبير يجب
الاشاره اليه الان يعني بكلمات اخرى ان
الصهيونيه الدينيه او الاستيطانيه او او
كل هذا المعسكر تحديدا الايديولوجي بات
يعسكر بات عفوا يسيطر اكثر فاكثر حتى على
توجهات الجيش وتحديدا على جنود المشابه
اكثرهم من من من هذا المعسكر الايديولوجي
فواضح جدا ان هنالك كذلك مفاهيم معينه
بكيفيه التوغل وكيفيه التواجد في داخل
الميدان وهنا ربما يجدر الاشاره الى نقطه
مهمه جدا ان اسرائيل الان تحديدا في كل ما
قام به بنيامين نتنياهو وعلى مدى العشره
اشهر السابقه موجوده بين معسكرين معسكر
يقدس اليهودي الانسان وهو بطبيعه الحال
المعسكر اليساري ومعسكر الذي يقدس اسرائيل
الارض وهو بطبيعه الحال اليميني اليمين
متطرف حتى انش